you've been through this roller coaster
of a couple years and I was sitting with
the final strophe that MVP trophy next
to you again and I'm curious how these
couple years have changed you as a man
and changed the way you look at faith
and kind of your priorities in life well
just a year last year you know a lot of
people were doubting me you know thought
I was either faking an injury or didn't
want to play for a team you know thought
I was disappointing to me that all that
was out in the media because I love the
game of basketball like I always say if
we're not playing his games is and for
hurt I mean you're down so me just you
know going through that and you know I
just knew that I'll have to make myself
happy
and no one else and I have to trust
myself and whatever what it doesn't
matter what anybody has to say about me
I Know Who I am as a person I know how I
feel and always just trust herself and
that was my goal and my focus is saying
you know that's why did it one of the
things that you know I take on the floor
I don't care about what media has to say
about me or one if they want me to score
whatever thirty points because I did the
game before I'm gonna come out and play
the right way I'm not trying to make
headlines and you know those that's just
things that you know I pretty much
learned just throughout this journey of
being in the NBA and so I mean that's
that's how I've just keep growing up as
a man and unless why I say I'll just
think about my past life and try to
learn from situations and be and be wise
and learn from others